alexi received the following problem a
particle moves in a straight line with
velocity v of t is equal to negative t
squared plus 8 meters per second where t
is time in seconds at t is equal to 2
the particle's distance from the
starting point was 5 meters
what is the total distance the particle
has traveled between t equals 2 and t
equals 6 seconds which expression should
alexis use to solve the problem so we
don't actually have to figure the actual
answer out we just have to figure out
what is the appropriate expression so
like always pause this video and see if
you can work through it on your own so
now let's tackle this together so the
key question is what is the total
distance the particle has traveled
between t equals two and t equals six so
we just care what happens between those
points we don't care that the particle's
distance from the starting point was
five meters at t equals two so this
right over here is actually unnecessary
information
so the first thing that you might want
to think about is well maybe distance is
just the integral of the velocity
function we've seen that multiple times
if you want to find the change in a
quantity you just say the starting time
and the ending time and then you
integrate the rate function so wouldn't
it just to be that
now we have to be very very careful
if the question was what is the
displacement for the particle between
time equals 2 and times equals 6 this
would have been the correct answer so
this would be
displacement
from
t equals 2
to
t is equal to 6. but they're not saying
displacement they're saying total
distance the particle has traveled so
this is the total
path length for the particle so one way
to think about it this is you would
integrate not the velocity function this
would if you integrate velocity you get
displacement instead you would integrate
the speed function now what is speed it
is the magnitude of velocity in one
dimension it would just be the absolute
value of your velocity function and so
the absolute value of the velocity
function this would give you integrating
the speed this would give you the
distance
from
t equals 2 to t is equal to 6 and let's
see we have that choice right over here
the displacement one here this is an
interesting distractor but that is not
going to be the choice this one right
over here v prime of 6
that gives you
the acceleration if you're taking the
derivative of the velocity function the
acceleration at 6 seconds that's not
what we're interested in and this gives
you
the absolute difference in velocity
between time six and time two that's not
what we're trying to figure out either